ja endlich ein go aus Deutschland für
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge für die Ukraine
nämlich den Dingo doch bevor wir uns den
Dingo etwas näher ansehen wollen wir uns
die Lage im Osten des Landes ansehen da
herrscht er die Frage wie sieht es aus
nach der erfolgreichen Großoffensive der
Ukraine hier oben im Raum Kaki macht die
weiter oder hört die auf und die Antwort
ist relativ klar es geht weiter die
Ukraine versucht hier weiter
vorzudringen und zwar nicht hier wo die
Russen zurückgedrängt hat hier an den
Fluss ostkol da geht es nicht weiter da
ist ein breiter Fluss der die beiden
Parteien voneinander trennt sondern man
versucht hier südlich von easium
vorzudringen man versucht hier in die
Wälder vorzudringen in der nördlichen
Region donetz und von dort aus haben wir
aktuelle Bilder und die haben es in sich
die sind aus dem Wort aus dem Ort die
Browser das ist ein kleines Dorf und wir
sehen hier wie russische Soldaten ein
Haus besetzen gefilmt von einer
ukrainischen Drohne und im Normalfall
sehen wir kurz danach Artillerie
Einschläge die die Drohne filmt diesmal
ist es anders die haben Special Forces
ukrainische Spezialeinheiten die
versuchen genau dieses Haus was wir
davon oben immer wieder sehen zu stürmen
das heißt wir haben hier keine schweren
Waffen keine Artillerie sondern wir
haben wirklich Soldaten die eben mit
ihren gewähren teilweise auch mit
Schalldämpfer drauf sind also
spezialinhalten und eben mit
Handgranaten auf dieses russische Haus
vordringen wo wir eben gesehen haben wo
sich etwa 20 30 Russen drin verschanzt
haben und die versuchen immer weiter
reinzugehen und wir sehen tatsächlich
dieses ja was man sonst vielleicht nur
aus aus Actionfilm kennt diese Aufnahmen
dass ein ukrainischer Spezialeinheit
hier steht und dann tatsächlich mit mit
der Granate hier sehen wir es geht ja an
den Keller ran und schmeißt die Granate
in den Keller rein wo die Russen sich
befinden und kurz danach haben wir die
Explosion also tatsächlich Mann gegen
Mann Kämpfe hier in der Ostukraine
parallel natürlich auch zu den schweren
Waffen parallel zu den ganzen Atelier
und Raketen Feuer was gegeneinander
gerichtet wird aber das gibt es eben
auch wirkliche Mann gegen Mann Kämpfe in
der Ostukraine jetzt in der Region
donetski hier versucht die Ukraine
weiter vorzudringen die Russen versuchen
hier verzweifelt ihre Linie zu halten
damit die Ukrainer weiter vollbringen
können brauchen sie eben westliches
Gerät und sie brauchen vor allem auch
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge und die wurden
gestern endlich zugesagt der Dingo da
sehen wir ihn einmal in Afghanistan das
ist ein richtiges Video der Bundeswehr
um das ganze zu erklären der eben auch
nach Afghanistan durch die Bundeswehr
eingesetzt wurde der soll jetzt auf dem
Weg sein im September gibt es die
Ausbildung und danach sollen 50 Dingo
geliefert werden hier sehen wir also
einmal einen Aufriss das der Dingo hat
12,5 Tonnen ist also massig sehr viele
Panzerung aber auch ein starker Motor
auf 5 Meter Länge und der Dingo soll den
Ukrainern eben dabei helfen sich voran
zu bewegen schnell voran zu bewegen und
die Frage ist ob er bewaffnet oder
unbewaffnet kommt wir sehen uns hier es
gibt den Dinge in verschiedenen
Ausführungen einmal mit einem
automatisierten Waffensystem aber auch
mit einem entweder MG3 also hier so
automatisierte MG3 oder mg 50 was man
dann wirklich tatsächlich noch direkt
händisch darauf laden kann wir sehen uns
auch sowas ist möglich wäre auch dass
die Ukraine überhaupt gar keine Waffen
dazu kriegt weil man sagt sie ihr habt
ja eure eigenen schweren Gewehre die
könnt oben drauf stellen mit denen kommt
ja auch besser klar neben dem Fahrer
können weitere sieben Personen sich
darin bewegen und das ist eben für die
Ukrainer wichtig dass man schnell
gepanzert vorankommt ins Feindes Gebiet
und dort wie wir es hier sehen in
Afghanistan wiederum die Leute ab setzt
die Soldaten nicht nur Deutschland
liefert sondern wir haben ja ganz neues
Video was ich auch noch mal zeigen
möchte auch Finnland liefert neue
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge und zwar sogar so
eine Art gepanzerten Bus ist der sie so
xa 180 der ist schon relativ alt ist aus
den 80er Jahren aber wir sehen hier
erstmals Aufnahmen wenn man mal zählen
wie fünf Stück von diesem gepanzerten
Bussen wenn man so will in der Ukraine
angekommen sind und das Besondere wir
sehen uns hier hinten die können auch
schwimmen das ist für die Ukraine auch
sehr wichtig es gibt zahlreiche Flüsse
im Osten des Landes habe ich gesagt den
oscoll in rakiv den severo donetz in der
in der Region luhansk im Süden natürlich
den die nepke die man überqueren muss
wenn man die Russen zurückschlagen will
im eigenen Land und insofern sind solche
schwimmfahrzeuge extrem wichtig als
letztes wollen wir uns ansehen was die
Russen machen denn auch die Russen sind
nicht tatenlos die Rus wir haben es
gehört bis zu 300 Panzer und gepanzerte
Fahrzeuge in der OST Ukraine gerade in
der Schlacht um kraki verloren und Sie
kommen jetzt mit neuen Waffen und das
ist ein ziemlich mysteriöses Video es
zeigt nämlich was die Russen behaupten
erstmal das alte nicht alte noch relativ
neue T90 aus einem Lager geholt werden
aber das sind die um welche Themen 90
sondern sogenannte t90s die eigentlich
für den Export bestimmt waren insofern
kann das aus dem Lager holen schon mal
überhaupt nicht stimmen sondern entweder
waren das Panzer die Russland eigentlich
zum Beispiel nach Indien oder Algerien
exportieren wollte und jetzt eben nicht
mehr exportieren kann weil man sie in
der Ukraine braucht oder und das wäre
ziemlich skandalös Indien oder Algerien
haben diese Panzer zurückgeschickt haben
also die bereits 2014 teilweise
erhaltene t90s zurückgeschickt nach
Russland damit im Russland sie selbst
einsetzen kann um eigene Krieg wir sehen
auf jeden Fall Putin hat riesige
Probleme nicht nur was seine Männer
angeht sondern auch was ein Panzer
angeht und muss jetzt auf jeden Fall auf
Panzer setzen die eigentlich überhaupt
nicht für den Krieg Russland bestimmt
waren
[Musik]